first thank for inviting me to give this
park and also particularly for coming up
with this cool title for my talk I felt
like I needed to at least make an effort
to sound like an expert on the topic I'm
talking about so the first thing I did
was to look up the word quintessential
and apparently it means representing the
most perfect or typical example of a
quality art class so the good news is
that you know I I'm happy to learn that
I am I'm working on the quintessential
computer science problem maybe I'll
change my webpage to call myself a
quintessential computer scientist so I
also want to mention not only its
consensus the quintessential computer
science problem it's also quick it
should also be a quintessential crypto
problem I think like maybe majority of
the audience here are from crypto
community and and we know that for
instance the this amazing line of work
on multi-party computation basically
assumes broadcast channel as given and
the work consensus is trying to solve to
open this this box and try to solve the
broadcast problem for this reason when
we submit consensus papers to crypto
conferences and also to ePrint they
should not be rejected because it's not
a quintessential crypto problem
okay I love the work of the most
conversation was how to use private
channel futures for example could she
progress
it's not all of them assume broadcast
given but a lot of them using
cryptography to achieved or hear
something yes so also a lot of these
consensus protocol to use crypto as a
building block like signatures and hash
functions are often used so there's a
very deep connection between so I'll be
pretty short on the motivation right we
know all these decentralized
cryptocurrency Bitcoin theorem and what
enables these fully decentralized
systems is a car abstraction called
distributed consensus and that's what we
are going to discuss today so the plan
is the following
I'll start with explaining single-shot
consensus often called basing agreement
I am going to go over some classical
upper bounds and lower bounds and then
in the second half of the talk I'm going
to talk about blockchain constructions
so flooding is like repeatedly reaching
consensus over time whereas single short
consensus or Byzantine agreement tries
to solve the consensus problem once the
stability
consensus mathematically has been it has
been realized over the years they just
found a mathematical point of view
consensus means we agree on one thing
suppose now we have ten proposals and we
agree on two things
does the mathematics the algorithms
distinguish between a green one and two
and in some way in some mathematical way
the mathematics do not distinguish
between the two and the only question is
as human beings does the question of
consensus a green goes to things as any
as any value so perhaps in blockchain
it's an adventurous appetite that's a
very good point maybe I can try to talk
about this when we when we go to the
second part of the talk like why is it
interesting to have a blockchain as an
abstraction so maybe you could remind me
in the breaker can do
and I think Rafal in the afternoon we
will also try to motivate the blockchain
as an abstraction okay if you have any
questions please feel free to interrupt
more interacting the better
so essentially if you look at the talk
I'm going to start by talking about
results from the 1980s these are
classical results and then I'm going to
talk about some new very new work that
very recently came out and but still of
a classical nature but you know maybe
I'm going to try to use one blockchain
protocol to try to also one is to try to
answer some of the theoretical questions
that's raised by the the first part of
the talk and then but this also
hopefully I can provide some practical
perspective okay so what is presenting
agreement the definition was proposed in
the work by a lamp art piece and szostak
in 1982 imagine we have and generals
among them one is the commanding general
so these generals would like to reach
agreement on whether they want to attack
our retreat okay and then essentially
the commanding general receives an input
right he makes a decision whether he
want we want to attack our retreat and
he wants to broadcast this value to
everyone the problem is that there's no
native broadcast channel has there be a
native broadcast channel like the radio
or something he could have just like
shouted out loud on the radio instead we
are going to have a modern version of
the problem where the generals
communicate with each other over email
so they can sign emails to each other
they have good security best practice
like they use PGP to encrypt their email
so I can authenticate where the email is
coming from and if an honest general
sends an email then honest recipient
will receive it on the next morning so
let's say the generals they each have a
clock
well it's like past midnight you know
they wake up and they check that email
okay but the problem is that some of
these generals are corrupt like there
are traders and these corrupt generals
they're trying to disrupt the agreement
like for instance if the honest generals
they end up deciding on different things
like some attacks some retreat then this
can cause casualty and unfortunately the
commanding general can be corrupt too
but if the commanding general we're
honest he could just like send the same
bit to everyone and then everyone
listens to the commanding general any
questions about this problem so maybe to
understand the problem a little bit
better
let me first formally define the
security requirements first obviously
this is an agreement problem so we want
consistency consistency requires that
all of the honest generous output the
same bit okay if you and I about honest
you outputs bi output P prime then P
must be the same as B Prime
we are going to assume that the
execution can be randomized like for
instance a lot of these protocols use
digital signatures and stuff like the
signature could be randomized so we want
these security properties to hold for
output a negligible fraction of the
execution traces in fact actually for
the purpose of this talk we're mostly
just going to use signatures and hash
functions so if you are happy to assume
that it's like an ideal signature ideal
hash then you can basically pretend that
all these properties must hold with
probability 1 ok
so if you just only want consistency
then it's not really an interesting
problem because everyone can just output
a canonical output zero and then they
they're always guaranteed to have
consistency and to make the problem more
interesting we require also validity
which says that if the commanding
general is honest then all of the honest
notes output must be the commanding
generals input so this makes the problem
non-trivial
so to understand this abstraction a
little better it helps to look at some
strongman solutions and why they don't
work the first time and solution
obviously is you know we could all just
listen to the sender I'm also going to
cut the commanding general a sender
because the sender wants to broadcast
this message to everyone like the
problem here is that we want to
essentially realize a broadcast channel
but we are only given pairwise
communication channel okay well
obviously you know why doesn't this
solution work obviously this doesn't
work and why
the difference right so if the
commanding general is corrupt then he
can just like send different bits to
different people and people will end up
outputting differently the second
solution is majority vote it's also a
very natural protocol right so you know
this first drawn man says you know we
shouldn't just listen to the general the
commanding general perhaps we want to
collect everyone's sentiment so here's a
natural protocol the sender in round one
since its input be to everyone and then
when I received the bit from the sender
I'm going to vote and the bit I've
received if I receive two different bits
like maybe let's say I just vote on the
first bit I receive and my vote is
basically a signature on the bit
received from the sender and I'm going
to broadcast and multicast basically
send this vote to everyone and then in
the third round we collect all the votes
and we basically count the votes for
each bit and we are going to output the
the bit with majority with more number
of votes so maybe let me be a little bit
more precise let's say whatever has more
votes I'm going to output
so the question is is this protocol the
screen doesn't like the protocol so what
do you think of this protocol this seems
a little bit better than the first
strong memory because now we are not
just like relying on the the single guy
being honest if the majority is corrupt
then they can like more than half the
notes are corrupt than they can change
[Music]
so if Mark modern majority are corrupt
like they can vote differently to
different people but in fact I claim
that this protocol does not even defend
against a single corrupt no just just
imagine this is like can't compare and
output the bit with more votes
so but in fact it doesn't actually even
defend against a single corrupt node and
for instance here's and it know this is
the first algorithm that solves the
problem let's go over this attack
together and let's say the sender is
corrupt okay and exchange they're honest
and they know that they know the
symptoms you don't look at what the
sender sent you or the synthesis just
let's look at this attack so maybe
there's P 1 and P 2 there are three
parties let's say there are three
parties maybe let's say and there's n 4
4 4 4 4 source let's just assume P 1 is
a collection of n parties and P 2 is a
collection of n parties and the sender
is a single party so in total and is
equal to 2 n plus 1 and it's the total
number of parties so let's say in the
first round the sender will send 0 to
the sky and 2 to these people and he
sends one to these other people so now
everyone will vote and the red is the
vote right so now obviously these people
will vote for 0 and these people will
vote for 1 and that these votes are
broadcast sent to everyone right so
obviously now when you can't you can't
exactly n votes or 0 and then you're
going to count em votes for 1 and then
basically the sender is going to be the
tiebreaker so what he's going to do is
he can vote for 0 to these guys that he
can vote for one to these guys
they don't always ignore the sender
process so I mean like if you always
ignore the sender you always ignore the
sender the protocol may not have
termination because let's say there's a
even number of people in this case we
want to have also it's implicit that we
always want to have termination like the
protocol we must output something like
at the end of let's say a fixed number
of rounds okay so it's not allowed that
you know people just don't output so
it's all about it's all about the
setting the original setting was no
signature and just injustice ending you
know that if you were sick on somebody
you've got from from this sender for
this send them and that's it now oh no
signature and before you believe it
mostly it was self corrupt which means
that if you are corrupt you have to have
at least four pasta sauce so yeah we're
actually going to cover that lower bound
to like without the signature
[Music]
four notes for one correct that's like
yeah so that's going to be in the second
half of the first part okay basically I
guess these are very good points like
there are different variations of this
kind of voting protocol but I guess I
only picked one specific variant but I
guess the point is to show this is not a
trivial problem like none of these
intuitive and natural protocols like you
know they don't necessarily solve the
problem we can analyze all these other
variants - so I mean now what's next
right you know the very natural thing to
try is for people to keep it keep
comparing notes write this protocol is
like the sender sends something we
compare notes and we make a decision but
what about now we keep comparing notes
more and more to amplify the agreement
but the challenge is how to design a
protocol that captures this idea like no
we keep comparing notes from more and
more rounds and therefore I'm going to
talk about a very simple protocol byte
11 strong very well known result the
protocol assumes the PKI and everyone
knows everyone's public key right we are
using PGP to send secure our emails I'm
going to use the letter F to denote the
number of corrupt notes okay so here's
how the protocol works so initially
every node has a set e I so note I set
is cut E sub I and the set is empty at
the beginning so in round zero again the
sender's going to sign its input bit and
send it to everyone now for the next F
plus one rounds
everyone is going to do the following
let's say in brown R I'm going to look
at all the signatures I've received for
each each bit and before some pit I've
heard at least our signatures from
distinct nodes these signatures must be
come from distinct nodes and moreover it
must contain the standard signature so
if this house for some pit B and this
pit be currently is this B is not in my
set E sub I now I'm going to do the
following because I've collected a lot
of votes on the spit B and I want to
sign this bit B star sorry the pit is P
star I'm going to sign the pit P star
and I'm going to send the signature to
everyone but I will also include all the
signatures I've heard so far on P star
as well okay and I'm also going to add P
start to my set
aye aye
okay so the the key thing to keep in
mind is that Iran are I'm always going
to count at least our signatures around
well I want to see one signature from
the sender in round two I want to see
two signature to signatures wound up
which must come from the sender in round
three I want to see at least three
signatures one of which must come from
the sender if there's more that's fine
but just basically at least are okay so
I'm going to repeat this for F plus one
rounds where F is the number of corrupt
notes if you don't know the number of
corrupt notes you can just run it for n
plus 1 rounds where n is total number of
notes okay but let's imagine now we
actually we are aware of an upper bound
on the number of corrupt notes and at
the end of round F plus one we are going
to make a decision and the decision is
very natural I'm going to look at my
local set and if the set has only one
bit
I will output that bit otherwise if the
set is empty or if the set has both bits
in it I'm just going to output some
canonical output 0 like in the in the
case where this my set contains 0 our
two bits in some sense the sender must
be corrupt and in this case we don't
need validity and I mean you know we can
just output some canonical bit if the
sender is honest essentially at the end
of the protocol every honest note said
must have size 1 and we are going to
output the sender's improve it
any questions about the protocol if not
I'm going to like go over the proof is a
very simple protocol
okay so why does this protocol work the
first thing to see is the following
claim if in some run are let's say some
honest note I sorry you see work what's
how it is how many corruption so what
and this actually works against
arbitrary number of corruptions as long
so let's say F is arbitrary number of
corruption as long as I around the
protocol for F press one runs so you
know what that prefer to do just if you
don't know you can just run it for n
plus one around
okay so the first thing to observe is
that if in some round are some honest
node I has the bit B in its local set
then it must be the case that in the
next round everyone has the bit B in
their local set so if I have something
in this round you have it in the next
round that's what this lemma says
assuming we are both honest you must
have it in the next round or before that
if you didn't have it now you must have
it in the next round okay so how do we
prove something like this it's very
simple note I is honest right so if not
I has bit B in its local set remember
the protocol whenever I add something to
my local set I'm always going to share
all the signatures I've seen including
my own signature like I also add my own
signatures own signature to it and I'm
going to broadcast this to everyone
right so think of the moment where the
moment at which note I add this bit to
its local set let's say it was added in
some R & R prime so it must be that note
I have seen are at least R prime
signatures and in the run R Prime and in
that round he's going to add its own
signature and he's going to broadcast
all these R plus R prime plus 1
signatures to everyone so therefore in
the round R prime plus 1 everyone if
they had not added the bit to their
local set yet they will of course added
in the next round so a very simple proof
you just as if I'd know something now
you'll know it in the next round okay
I think maybe this is Qatar this
numbering is a little weird so this this
is I was going to cut the screen one
and then this let's cut this claim zero
okay so the next claim to observe is
that something magic happens in the last
round if I have something if an honest
guy i has the Pitt be in its local set
in the last round F plus one then it
must be that every honest guy has the
same Pitt be in the last round so now
this is talking about simultaneous if I
have it now you must have it now and
this holds for the last round so that's
why there's something interesting
happening here in person with the
previous screen and why is this true
okay
so essentially if in round F plus one
let's say if I have added be in some
prior round then already you know five
claim zero already everyone has must
have it in the next round so the only
case we need to care about is if I added
the spit in the last round right so if I
actually added this bit to its local set
in the last round it must be that I have
seen F plus one signatures at least of
plasma signatures in the last round on
the spit be
and because there are only F corrupt
notes at least one of these signatures
must come from an honest note right so
think about when that honest guy signed
a bit this must happen must have
happened in a prior round that's it in
some prior round our prime this honest
guy signed the pp and added added the PP
to its local set then it must be that in
run our prime plus one that everyone has
the bid be in its local set and this
follows from claim zero and the
interesting thing that's happening here
is basically if I see F plus one
signatures and the PP that one of them
must come from an honest note and
dishonest note must have signed it in in
a prior round and therefore in the next
round to that that round everyone will
have it okay
okay
so now we can kind of think about this
protocol and reflect upon it right so
one thing about this protocol is that if
there are F corrupt notes by the way
maybe I didn't make it clear like
throughout the talk I'm going to assume
corrupt notes can behave abot really
like they can give you opportunity from
the protocol place exactly that we use
the signature yeah that's a good
question so where is this place and
where we use signature this one doesn't
need to use signature security but in
this proof and when we say okay suppose
I've seen seen oppressed when signatures
one of them must come from an honest
note here we are using signature
security because if corrupt notes
adversary can fought for honest node
signature then it could happen that
they're honest I didn't sign this bit
and multicast it to everyone signature
if I replaced it if I received F must
mind messages on B from mystic node in
round F plus one so instead of saying
signature value just received from F
plus one and when I receive from
somebody I know that this somebody is
read somebody so if I have
point-to-point communication and I
replaced the signature looks like you
didn't use the signature and so it's so
magic is the same yeah so that's a very
good question so what if you don't have
signature and you change the protocol to
say you have to change for the Pearl
because here notes I think as one knows
this big yeah so like the current
protocol relies on the ability for
people to transfer the signatures right
like if if I put it to my local set I'm
going to tell everyone all the
signatures right now so it relies on the
ability to like relay these signatures
you know and we'll did you use it what
do you mean point-to-point my
communication
what do you mean I know that you sent
the message when I sent to you you know
that it's for me because we have a
dedicated line communication but
somebody could have cut the cable
[Music]
forward no we can pull the message
incorrect so the signature is currently
like you forward messages and you can
believe them without signatures you can
only believe things that we're seeing in
China so like if you look at the first
claim we realized on the fact that if I
know something now I'm able to transfer
all my knowledge to you like I'm going
to I can't demonstrate an evidence
here's why I have added to my set and
I'm going to add my signature to it and
then you are going to add it in the in
the next round to if there is no
signature I guess you can I have n to s
plus one signature and I'm forwarding
there plus one signature so this guy
will have of course my signature and you
don't have to rely on ok so here is the
signature right in the oldest is the
oldest now Helden helpful reference or
NLF plus one and he's sending he's
forcing everybody because he's holding f
plus one signatures of all the owners
now we see this big it's point-to-point
it's pairwise channels it's fully
connected so everyone can say you know
to everyone else like let's say everyone
knows everyone else is public key I can
send a message directly to you
by signing the email to you so what's
the reason for relaying this
I guess the the the challenge is if a
corrupt note just honest notes when they
send message they're going to send the
same message to everyone but if I'm a
corrupt note I don't have to do that
like I can send you zero and I can say
Raphael one so if you are going to make
a decision relying on my message from
the previous round you know
unfortunately you won't which you may
not reach the same decision right
because I can send equivocating messages
to different people especially what's
happening is that you're looking at this
attack and you're saying well with
signatures if I'm in p1 I can just like
send the Sutlej send whatever the sender
sent me to OB - I agree listen this is
what the sender told me love their
signature scent mean less their
signature during the center but we can
resolve everything in one round so we're
just adding more rounds and plus some
Smarties yeah we looked at this one went
around voting protocol right is we
compare notes once and that didn't quite
work so what made it work here is that
you have to apparently compare notes
multiple times and in fact you have to
do it for F plus one rounds
so this is a very interesting question
and in fact if without the signature I'm
going to prove a lower bound and next to
show that you actually have to have the
exact place of the signature okay
so okay so this protocol has F plus one
runs as you can see right you have to
compare notes F plus 1 number of times
and in fact this is somewhat inherent
and there is a I think this was also
proven in the toll-f strong paper but
the proof was rewritten several times by
and simplified by later work so there is
a well-known lower bound that showed for
any deterministic protocol it has to
incur F plus 1 rounds to defend against
F corrupt corrupt notes yeah even for
and the the proof works in the idea of
signature model even if the signature is
randomized if you are using the
signature in a blackbox way ok so this
is both good and bad right it's good in
the sense that we have a protocol that
can defend against a betrayal in many
corruptions very strong security but on
the other hand it's kind of expensive
because we have to you know repeat
essentially linear number of rounds
before we can reach agreement and
therefore a very natural question is
whether we can overcome this lower bound
with the randomization and this I'm
going to try to save to the second part
of the talk like when I talk about the
blockchain construction I can revisit
this question the answer is yes
obviously you can to expect a constant
number of rounds okay
like I said the protocol is nice in the
sense it defends against majority
corruption but it's not so nice in the
sense that we have to assume a PKI and
people have to be able to sign messages
so now the question is can we get rid of
this PKI right do we actually have to
have this assumption
oh yeah I guess we there's a lower bound
- it's not clear I think the only known
lower bound is look for any there's a
paper by cats at our show that you need
Omega and to an over F number of runs I
think over N minus F so like if F is a
half of n you need at least constant
number of runs so that's not too
interesting if F is very close to n then
you need linear number of runs
the answer here is not just yes or no
yeah it's more complicated so but at
least we can hope let's say for the
Amish majority the question is whether
we can do so this lower bound says if F
is let's say 1/2 n any deterministic
protocol must incur a linear number of
runs but the lower bound is saying ok if
F is like roughly half of n you know
maybe we can do constant number of
rounds can we actually achieve that with
randomized
okay
so can we remove the PKI and this is
like what you have been asking it's a
very good question let's try to
understand this question first how much
time do I have
give me 20 more minutes for the first ok
so I think we can't go over this this Oh
before that I want to before I conclude
that Olav strong I want to mention a
nice riddle it was originally presented
by Moses tell Evan how burning in this
nice paper it's a way to understand
common knowledge and it's kind of
remotely reminiscent to the toll-f Strom
protocol we have seen right so imagine
there's a village cheating husbands and
violent wives it may not be politically
not not saying that it's politically
correct but I'm just presenting it in
the way that was described in this paper
maybe next time I give a talk out you
know portray weenie as cheating and men
as a violent okay so here is the problem
so in this village the man's the man may
be cheating on their wives
the wives they gossip so they kind of
know whether other people's husbands are
cheating they don't know whether their
own husband is cheating or not so one
day some outsider comes into the village
and he announces you know there is at
least one husband cheating in the
village okay so now the wives every
night if the wife discovers that her
husband is cheating she's going to shoot
the husband
now the question is which and which day
do the husband's get shot nice riddle
yeah if you treat the cheating cheating
husbands as party right so imagine their
f40 husband then they all get shot on
the fda's essentially and the reason is
imagine of equal do one there's only one
cheating husband so then on the first
night and the this woman whose husband
is cheating she's going to discover that
no one she sees and no one else's
husband is cheating and she's convinced
that her own is cheating so she he would
she would shoot the husband so now we
can't do four F equal to turret if no
one gets shot on the first day then we
know that F is at least F is at least
two so on the second night if a woman
discovers that a man everyone else's
husbands only one is cheating that she
knows that her own is cheating so she
would shoot the husband on the second
day so you can do it inductively and
essentially the Ark occurred on Earth
Day
with the other wives okay but I'm not
cheating among each other otherwise it
would be too okay
so now I mean this is kind of
reminiscent to the left stronger because
the magic happens in the apps run FR f +
1 run okay so now let's go to this PKI
question do we actually need the PKI so
I'm going to prove a theorem that says
okay maybe you could do without the PKI
but not with such strong security and
I'm going to show that if we don't have
the PKI and there's only pairwise
channel pairwise authenticated channel
then one cannot hope to tolerate 1/3
corruptions or more and this is a
well-known result by oh I think it was
first proven in the lamp or paper and
played on the version I'm going to
present it's a simplified version by
Fischer Lynch and Merritt PKI of the
ballistic so just don't form
deterministic this result for randomized
protocol solicitude okay so let's just
revisit the model now we don't have the
PKI anymore so what's the difference
people cannot sign messages to each
other so let's say if Trini told me
something I'm not able to demonstrate
the signature - to you and convince your
destiny has said that okay and the model
is like still pairwise channels i we can
communicate with each other and I know
where exactly the message is coming back
okay so how do we prove something like
this here were the trying it's not a
correct proof yet so imagine let's turn
back the wheel of time to 2006 when
maybe Shafi was doing MIT and let's say
MIT wants to elect department chair and
the current Charlotte back then Sweeney
he makes a suggestion to chef Ian Silvio
so he decides the input and he sends the
input to both these people
and now Shafi claims to not now these
two people compare notes right so chef
he tells Sylvio you know Serena said
Sylvio like maybe none of them want to
be department chair they are they all
want to focus on crypto research so in
this example the key issue is like
because we don't have signatures any
more like Sharpie basically can claim
whatever she wants about what Sweeney
set and so well in this case cannot
distinguish whether three myths and
inconsistent messages to the two of them
or whether chef is corrupt it could be
that Chef is corrupt and so string is
honest suni send the same message to
about people push a fee is lying but it
could also be that Serena is like you
know dishonest and he sending
inconsistent messages
so if 3me is honest it must be the case
that Silvia and Serena must both up
about output Shafi right by validity but
if Trini is dishonest let's imagine the
protocol
I don't know output Silvia because if
it's like let's the canonical output is
Silvia if not we can flip the names
around so there is no it this guy can't
distinguish which case it is it's not a
formal proof like for one thing the
protocol doesn't have to look like this
it gives the intuition why does this
transferable transfer ability might be
important okay so how do we make this
proof correct yeah it's a Byzantine
thought so you could just are you asking
if the protocol if the theorem holds for
crash fault I don't think so
the theorem how it's only for Byzantine
fatalistic it's a structural you take
the triangle and you making the hexagon
yeah you said the key insight basically
the key insight it's the proof is a
hexagon it's not a triangle so what I
did was a triangle it should be a
hexagon like I went to grad school with
this friend and whenever we want go to
an Indian restaurant he would order a
hexagon shaped vegetable and the
waitress would be very very confused so
this is how I remember the proof
so here's how the correct proof works
it's I like this proof because it's very
simple but it's also in some ways are
intuitive because the first thing you
have to be comfortable with is imagining
a thought experiment like this is a
hypothetical execution we have six notes
like there's two copies of everyone and
everyone's running the honest protocol
so like for instance that's a blue
Sweeney right he sees that he's talking
to Silvio and Shafi this blue chef he
thinks she's talking to blue
Sweeney and red Silvio presently the
execution is must be well-defined this
is not something that would actually
happen in the real execution of the
protocol but let's imagine we kind of
create an exit hypothetical execution
like this and we are going to use this
hypothetical experiment to rule out
protocols that defend against 1/3
corruption actually that if somebody say
they did it yeah you can you could do it
can be done sure but this I think is
like the most to me it's like the most
unintuitive part of the proof like you
have to create this kind of thought
experiment with six notes not three and
and imagine we actually do have a
protocol that doesn't use PKI and that
it secures against one third corruption
so one of these guys is allowed to be
corrupt and the security properties must
still hurt if when only one is corrupt
okay
so imagine now the red srini receives
the input zero and the blue surimi
receives input one right so three knee
is still going to act as the sender okay
so now let's reason about this
hypothetical experiment and we are going
to think of it in several ways to reach
a contradiction if we can reach a
contradiction we can rule out such
protocols okay so the first way to
interpret it and you know it could be
that chef is corrupt and she's
simulating all this right-hand side in
her head in this case the red srini I
read Sylvia they're honest
okay now only one one person is corrupt
right so by validity if we interpret the
experiment like this then both these
people should output the bit zero okay
so if you are okay with this then I'm
just going to claim by symmetry these
two people will output one okay
so that's not enough to reach a
contradiction yet
now we can interpret the experiment in a
different way so imagine Sylvia to
corrupt corrupt guy and he is simulating
this yellow part in his head
and now the red srini and red Shafi
they're honest okay so now we can use
the validity property again right so if
we viewed the execution like this only
one guy's corrupt and by validity the
honest people must output the sender's
bit which is zero so these two people
must output zero
now if you are comfortable with this
stand by symmetry blue Shafi must output
one we are getting close so far we have
only used validity and to reach a
contradiction we have to use consistency
at least once obviously so now finally
that's let's view the execution as
follows imagine three needs the one
who's actually corrupt the standards
actually corrupt and Sweeney is
simulating this yellow part in his head
and in this case the blue silver and red
Shafi they are honest okay so only one
guy's corrupt and we must have
consistency so therefore it cannot be
the case that Shafi up the red Shafi
output zero blue silver outputs one we
have reached a contradiction
this basically rules out protocols like
this like protocols that don't use PKI
the secure against winter corruption the
proof works for randomized protocols -
like what I said is like assuming with
probability 1 but you can you know
everything is reasoning about this
hypothetical experiment you can put in
the probabilities and it'll still work
with like broad range of parameters
allow the protocol to fail even with
like 1/3 probability majority voting is
1/3 you can do the calculation more
carefully off like that I just want to
point out that this requires this the
adversary to simulate in this example
for nose so this is under the model that
the adversary has ability to have see
when I mean a simulation field business
situation we don't assume to assume a
weak gravity very good under the
assumption that their adversary
cannot simulate tomato-y a proof-of-work
makes it if you assume each of these
parties as one unit of computation power
then the adversary is not necessarily
able to simulate four nodes the corrupt
node is not necessarily able to generate
four noting attacks but in this case but
I think a good point is in order for the
corrupt guy to be able to simulate these
four nodes in his head but if you had
PKI they wouldn't be able to do that
because like for instance Shafi could
have a public key and three missing
Sweeney doesn't have the corresponding
secret key like he wouldn't be able to
make the simulation in his head and
that's why the proof doesn't work if
there's a there's a PKI
if the adversary is weak enough then you
can steal this lower bound will not hold
yeah if you impose other resource
constraints and Alabama novel
very relaxed question relaxation of the
consciousness problem which this does
not strictly applies in which the
relaxed problem says in a safely the
shape free one nobody field you have to
do it notion called weak validity like
in this example there is a that
designated sender and the sender is
trying to broadcast and in the agreement
version everyone receives an input
consistency is the same as before and
validity there are two versions one is
like the stronger version is odd honest
notes that there are subtly different
the stronger version in the agreement
version is like if other honest notes
receive the same input then everyone
must output that bit so that's cut I
don't this is the agreement version and
for this version you basically
automatically need honest majority there
is a weaker version that says validity
only needs to hold if everyone's honest
and everyone receives the same input and
for that I think there's still a 1/3
lower bound and that's proven in the
same paper by Fisher Lynch and merit the
proof is an extension of this I think
you have to create a cycle of
proportional to number of rounds of the
the protocol it's a very elegant proof
so you guys
it's not for a consular publish this
this gives you this allows so I guess we
can wrap up this part it's good timing
we looked at the dollar Strom protocol
it assumes PKI defense against arbitrary
number of corruptions but the the
drawback is it takes a long time to
reach agreement we kind of provide a
partial answer to the first question
right is this PKI necessary it is kind
of necessary if you want to defend
against a lot of corruptions but what I
haven't mentioned is that so there is
this lower bound that says we need 1/3
and indeed it's actually possible to
construct a protocol without a PKI that
secures against fewer than want their
corruptions
so this is a tight lower bound I'm not
going to talk about the construction
that's the first question we want to
understand the second question I'm going
to just save it for later like I'm
actually not going to directly try to
enter this question there's a line of
work that tries to construct expected
constant run through the cost for the
honest majority setting I will in the
second part of the talk I'll cover block
chains and then I'll try to revisit this
question
[Applause]